this week marks 35 years since 48 Hours
went on the air making it the longest
running True Crime program on television
tomorrow night 48 Hours investigates a
case of a missing girl and three other
young women who all appear to be
connected to one serial killer Aaron
Moriarty brings us the final chapter of
a story she first started reporting on
in 1997.
when Laura Smither went missing during a
morning jog on April 3rd 1997 in
Friendswood Texas the search for the
missing 12 year old took on massive
proportions
I was there with Laura's parents Bob and
gay Smither as they look for their
daughter are you surprised by the
outpouring of concern Sympathy uplifted
by it it's just the only thing that's
getting us from one day to the next on
April 20th came the terrible news
Laura's body was found in a retention
Pond 12 miles from their home I screamed
into the phone that's not Laura that's
not Laura that's I couldn't accept it I
can still hear my screens in my not base
soon a suspect emerged a sex offender
who worked down the road from the
Smithers home his name William Reese it
was the third day that Laura was missing
that he was on the police radar
investigators Trace fibers from Laura's
socks to fibers from Reese's truck floor
mats into a horse blanket found in his
home but the D.A at the time didn't feel
it was enough to prosecute and Laura's
case remained officially unsolved for
close to two decades I got very very
angry I felt that the system had failed
us and failed Laura investigators
suspected Reese may have been
responsible for more murders and in 2014
DNA results connected him to the murder
of Tiffany Johnson in Oklahoma they
wondered if this might give them
leverage to persuade him to talk about
Laura Smither and two missing person
cases in Texas Jessica Kane and Kelly
Cox to their surprise he agreed I had no
reason lying you guys but friends with
Deputy Chief of Police Josh Rogers says
not everyone thought they could trust
William Reese there was some folks
thinking that maybe the information was
not accurate and that he was playing us
Aaron Moriarty joins us now thanks for
being here first of all you started this
case in 1997 when it first broke what
Drew you to it well at that time in 1997
friends with Texas was considered to be
one of the safest towns in America in
this 12 year old disappears and you we
all know that is a parent's worst
nightmare and then just to add to that
why it stayed with me is my child was
the same age yes birthday the same month
and I could not get it out of my head
even when I left and we focused on it
because of course when she first
disappeared we wanted maybe she'd be
found and then when she couldn't be
found maybe her killer would be found
but I would never have guessed that's
the advantage of staying on a story so
long how the story really developed yeah
boy we were going to be tuning in that
is a case of all cases Sarah Moriarty uh
thank you and you can see Aaron's report
the daughters who disappeared on 48
hours tomorrow night at 10 9 Central
right here on CBS and on our streaming
service Paramount Plus